MANO MARKS: Hello, and welcome
to a special episode of Google
Developers Live with Google
Maps and Android.
I'm Mano Marks of the Maps
developer relations team.
And this week, I'm teamed
up with Fred Chung
on the Android team.
FRED CHUNG: Hello everyone.
MANO MARKS: We'd like to talk
to you about the new Google
Maps Android API V2.
FRED CHUNG: So yeah, we just
launched Google Play Services.
It's an update to Google
Play Services.
For those of you that aren't
familiar with Google Play
Services, it is a new platform
through which third-party
developers, Android developers
can integrate with Google
services like Google Plus,
OAuth 2.0 authentication.
And now they can also integrate
with Panorama and
Maps, the new Maps API
through this service.
And the good thing is that
this service is backward
compatible all the way
back to Froyo or 2.2.
And the beauty of this is that
for users, as new updates
become available, the users
automatically get the new
services on their devices.
And for developers, all you have
to do is to grab a thin
client library to integrate
with your Android project.
MANO MARKS: In this update, we
added a number of interesting
components.
In particular today, we're going
to talk to you about
Google Maps Android API V2.
In this new map library, we're
making available to all
Android apps the same experience
that Android users
get using the Google Maps app.
You're going to get
vector tiles.
You can rotate and
tilt the map.
And these interactions are
something that users are
already familiar with.
So if you just take a quick look
here, you can see here we
are in a tilted map view
with 3D buildings.
If I zoom in, you can see that I
actually have some access to
some indoor maps.
So here we have Moscone
Center West.
I can also switch very quickly
to terrain mode.
FRED CHUNG: Very nice.
MANO MARKS: Or I can switch
to hybrid, satellite,
and vector data mode.
And one of the really cool
call-out features on this is
you will notice that
as I rotate this
map, which I can do--
rotate and tilt it--
the labels all stay in
the same direction.
Even though this is a raster
map, it's got vector overlay
on top of it.
FRED CHUNG: So I don't
need to turn my head.
So essentially, the experience
is just like Google Maps.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
And anywhere I go, I can
get traffic data.
So whatever layer I'm looking
at, I get an overlay of
traffic if that's what I want
to show to my users.
--users are already
familiar with.
So if you just take a quick look
here, you can see here we
are in a tilted map view
with 3D buildings.
If I zoom in, you can see that I
actually have some access to
use some indoor maps.
So here we have Moscone
Center West.
I can also switch very quickly
to terrain mode.
FRED CHUNG: Very nice.
MANO MARKS: Or I can switch
to hybrid, satellite,
and vector data mode.
And one of the really cool
call-out features on this is
you will notice that
as I rotate this
map, which I can do--
rotate and tilt it--
the labels all stay in
the same direction.
Even though this is a raster
map, it's got a vector overlay
on top of it.
FRED CHUNG: So I don't
need to turn my head.
So essentially, the experience
is just like Google Maps.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
And anywhere I go, I can
get traffic data.
So whatever layer I'm looking
at, I get an overlay of
traffic if that's what I want
to show to my users.
FRED CHUNG: I talk to
a lot of developers.
And I know that this update
is much anticipated.
I'm sure a lot of them will be
thrilled about this update.
So from a coding perspective,
this new library addresses a
couple of developer concerns.
It is now fragment friendly,
which is a good thing.
Because this is one of the major
concerns that we hear a
lot from the developers
trying to use
the old MapView libraries.
There are some limitations
to it.
It can only be hosted in
[? a map ?] activity, which is
kind of limiting for a
lot of developers.
People have tried all sorts
of tricks to make
it work with fragments.
But it's very messy.
So the good thing is that
it is now available.
So feel free to update your
app to this new API.
For today's show, there
are two parts to it.
In the first part, Mano will do
some more additional demos
to show off some
of the features
available in this API.
And then we'll hang out with a
couple of developers, Trulia
and Expedia hotels
and flights.
Both of them have started using
the API to migrate their
existing maps to this new API.
So we're going to listen to what
they have to share with
the audience.
MANO MARKS: Probably the best
way to learn about the new API
and what it can do is
to see these awesome
new features in action.
I've installed the Google Maps
Android API Demo app-- that's
a really long name--
FRED CHUNG: It is.
MANO MARKS: --on this tablet
as you've been seeing.
And I'll show you the main
features of the new API.
The source code for this app is
actually part of the Google
Play Services package that
you can get with
the Android SDK manager.
We're planning to cover
more technical
details in future shows.
But in the meantime, you can
check out the code for the
demo app to get a better feel
for how the API works.
So you'll see that there's
actually a ton of demos here.
And we're going to just show you
a few of the really cool
and interesting things that
are new in the new Maps.
So here, we have a sample
app that shows you
how the camera works.
So because you have this sort
of bearing and tilt of the
map, you can also control the
zoom and center of the map.
This is something that not only
your users can do through
the UI but you can also
do programmatically.
So if you'll see here, I'm
looking at Sydney.
The Maps team is in Sydney,
the engineering team.
So that's why we always have
these Sydney demos.
FRED CHUNG: I wonder why.
MANO MARKS: So here I
can go to Sydney.
You see this gets this
nice, smooth, and
quick transition here.
Also, I can go to Bondi, which
is a beach nearby.
And you'll see how it does that
nice, smooth animation
but also tilted and zoomed
it at the same time
and rotated the map.
FRED CHUNG: It's kind of like
the Google Earth experience.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, it is
very much like that.
And then if I turn off
animation, I can just go
directly there.
So these sort of things you get
also different kinds of
animations built in for both
zooming and moving in this for
short hops as well.
FRED CHUNG: Very nice.
MANO MARKS: The next thing I'm
going to show you is ground
overlays just really quickly.
This is something that users of
the JavaScript Maps API are
familiar with.
But you'll see here I've
actually overlaid an old
raster image on top
of the map.
And along with that,
I get this nice
sort of tilting effect.
So this is something you can
use your geolocated--
your georeferenced
raster imagery.
And then you can do things
like control the
transparency there.
It's a great way to showcase
old and new data together.
FRED CHUNG: So, Mano,
one quick question.
Can you use any arbitrary
images?
MANO MARKS: Yeah, you could put
my face on your map if you
really wanted to.
Not that anybody
would do that.
I would really suggest
you not do that.
Because that's going
to be a little
surprising for the users.
So let's take a look
at markers.
You get new features
with markers here.
First of all, we get the
standard default info window.
You can also customize the
contents of the info window.
So you get a little bit more
interesting interaction there.
You can also customize the
info window itself.
So you see here it's got these
sort of rounded corners.
But not only that, your markers
can be draggable.
So here, I'm just dragging
that marker.
And as I drag it, I get a
on-marker drag end event,
which then you can do
something with.
This is a great way for allowing
people to collect
data for you.
Or you could use this for
positioning in games or
anything like that.
You can provide your own
custom icons as well.
And yeah, I think these
are great new
features and markers.
Quickly just show you
this fun one.
You don't have to use our
map tiles if you want.
You can use this as a serving
technology for
your own map tiles.
FRED CHUNG: So what are
we looking at now?
MANO MARKS: We're looking
at the moon.
Google Maps has published tile
overlays for the moon.
And as you see, we have
these raster images.
And I can do some nice movement
around using these
raster tiles.
I can turn them.
FRED CHUNG: It's really cool
that you can tap into the
basic infrastructure for
manipulating a UI while using
your own overlay.
It would be an ideal tool for
game developers, for example.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
And you can do custom tiles,
custom tile projections.
You don't have to use the
standard Mercator projection.
FRED CHUNG: Nice.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
OK, polygons.
Polygons are new in this API.
And you can see you've got
lots of ways that you can
control how polygons
look and feel.
So polygons are basically
a line with fill.
You can change the
fill hue here.
You can change the fill
alpha as well.
You can change the
stroke width.
And you'll see you also have
nice little holes in your
polygons and a lot of new
features as well.
We also have poly lines, which
are basically polygons without
the fill in them.
Those give you interesting
features, like you can do a
geodesic poly line.
So they match the curvature
of the earth rather than a
direct, straight line.
Then finally, I wanted
to demonstrate for
you multiple maps.
Now, because maps are
now in a fragment--
FRED CHUNG: That's a big win.
MANO MARKS: It's a big win.
So you longer have to
extend map activity.
Maps can now be added
to any activity.
And you can also add
them to fragments.
You can see one of the results
of that is you can do multiple
maps in the same view.
FRED CHUNG: That's very cool.
MANO MARKS: So that's nice
if you want to do sort of
side-by-side comparisons.
FRED CHUNG: Definitely.
All right, great.
Thanks for demos, Mano.
Now, let's have a look at what
some of the early adopters are
doing with the API.
Hello.
We have invited Trulia
on air today.
We have two representatives
from
Trulia, Stephen and Alice.
Stephen and Alice, do you
guys want to do a quick
introduction.
STEPHEN: Sure.
Thank you Fred.
Thanks for this opportunity.
We're here to introduce
Trulia.
We have a great Trulia Android
engineering team here.
And what Trulia is, first of all
to set it up, we are a US
residential property
search site.
And mobile is extremely
important to us.
Mobile is the fastest growing
part of our traffic right now.
It's up over 140%
year on year.
And currently is over 30% of our
traffic on a weekly basis.
So mobile is very
important to us.
And Android, particularly, is
a big part of that as well.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
So you have a tablet app
in Google Play store.
Well, you actually have
multiple apps.
And I understand that you have
spent some time working with
the new maps API.
And let's go ahead and have a
look at what you've done with
it, shall we?
STEPHEN: Sure, let's do it.
FRED CHUNG: So I've gone ahead
and launched the tablet
version, which looks great.
I'm looking at San Francisco,
downtown San Francisco.
I see a bunch of properties, a
bunch of expensive properties.
As I'm panning the map around,
I notice that you guys have
incorporated the new API.
So you can see the tilting.
As I zoom in closer and closer,
3D buildings begin to
pop up any minute.
And in certain locations you do
also have the indoor maps
available from the API,
which is awesome.
So as I click on one of the
markers, a pop up shows up,
showing me some property.
I clicked on it.
A pane shows up with some
more property details.
So that's kind of cool.
STEPHEN: Yes.
This is what users really
enjoy about us.
They can look for properties.
They can see photos.
We have big photos,
a lot of cases.
And then if they want, they
can contact a real estate
agent right from that property
page that you're looking at.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
STEPHEN: So we've really focused
on making that a great
experience for them.
FRED CHUNG: Right.
And I notice that you guys have
incorporated a couple of
interesting features.
The first one that I'd like to
touch on is the layer, custom
layer information.
As I click on the Layer icon,
a pop up comes up.
And I'm going to go ahead and
click on Crime layer.
Can you walk us through a little
bit on how the crime
data layer is rendered?
It looks pretty visually
appealing right now.
ALICE: Yeah, we used the new
tile overlay the new API
[? provide ?] that we're easily
just give the URL of
our tiles and then it will
render nicely on the map.
FRED CHUNG: Cool.
And I also understand that
there's a feature.
There's a pretty cool feature
where you can hand draw an
arbitrary polygon, an
arbitrary shape.
And in the app, it's going to
do a search based on the
hand-drawn area.
STEPHEN: Draw search, you can
draw your own search in the
area you want.
And we really try to focus on
giving you the inside scoop.
So not only property details,
but crime, as you looked at,
school attendance [? zone, ?]
zip code boundaries, and things
around the area that
users are interested
in when they're
looking for a property.
FRED CHUNG: Yeah, it's
very interactive.
Good job, guys.
STEPHEN: Thank you.
FRED CHUNG: So can you maybe
share a little bit more
information on your experience
using the new Maps API?
From an engineering standpoint,
what sort of
effort is needed?
ALICE: The new app Map API
provides a lot of new features
that we were looking
for before.
For example, the support
maps [INAUDIBLE]
that we no longer need to
use a revised version,
[? our own. ?]
We can use the default one.
And the camera and camera
[INAUDIBLE]
[? event ?] change is great that
we don't need to handle
[? the touch ?]
[? event ?] and figure out if
maps [INAUDIBLE] or not.
The custom info window
that is kind of
nicely tied with a marker.
So it's great.
Yeah, these are the great
features that it's-- the
migration is about a week or
two effort to make our app
really stable.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
You mentioned fragment.
I personally anticipated that
fragment would be one feature
that a lot of Android
developers
would be excited about.
So that's great.
Do you have a separate phone
app and a tablet app?
Or what's your model like?
ALICE: Yeah, we have two form
factors, one for X-large
devices and one for others.
So X-large device would be
10-inch tablet and larger.
FRED CHUNG: Right.
But you are using one APK for
the two form factors, right?
Got it.
Is this app available with
the new Maps API?
STEPHEN: Yes, this app is
available as soon as the new
Maps API is public.
This app that you're looking
at today will be available.
All of our apps are free.
We actually have three top-rated
Android apps.
And this is our main app.
It'll be available
as soon as the
Google Maps API is available.
FRED CHUNG: Awesome.
Cool.
So I look forward to seeing you
upgrade the other apps to
the new Maps API.
STEPHEN: That will
be coming soon.
FRED CHUNG: All right, great.
Thanks, guys.
STEPHEN: Thank you.
ALICE: Thank you.
FRED CHUNG: Hello.
We have invited Dan Lew
from Expedia hotels
with us here on-air.
DAN LEW: Hi.
FRED CHUNG: Dan is the Android
developer behind Expedia
Hotels and Flights application
and the FlightTrack
application.
He is here to share with us some
of his experience using
the new Maps API.
I understand that, Dan, you guys
have started looking into
the API and have started
incorporating the API into the
two apps that I just
mentioned, right?
DAN LEW: Yeah.
It's been working out
great so far.
It's really jumped
past the previous
version of the Maps library.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
So shall we do a quick walk
through of the application?
Let's start with Expedia
hotels and flights.
My understanding is that you
just recently launched an
update to this beautiful app.
And then you're in the process
of updating the map portion of
it with the new Maps API.
DAN LEW: Mm hm.
FRED CHUNG: I'm at the
landing screen.
And I'm scrolling through.
And it's what seems to
be an infinite list
view of pretty pictures.
And let's get into the
hotels portion.
Can you walk us through what's
available there?
DAN LEW: Yeah, I mean it's a
pretty simple idea, which is
simply that on the hotel side,
you can search for a location.
And there is the traditional
list view of just hotels.
But if you click the button on
the bottom right, it will
switch you over to a map view
version of the application.
FRED CHUNG: There you go.
I can see in this demo version,
you are using the
vector-based map so that
I can twist, and turn,
and tilt the tiles.
DAN LEW: Yeah.
FRED CHUNG: That's
pretty cool.
And right now, I'm trying
to search for
hotels in San Francisco.
So it brought me to San
Francisco with a nice
animation, flyover animation.
So that's something that's
supported by the new API.
DAN LEW: Yep.
FRED CHUNG: So as I zoom closer
into the clusters of
hotels in downtown San
Francisco, I can click on the
markers as you would expect.
And are these custom markers?
DAN LEW: Yeah, we have our
own assets for those.
But we also played around with
the different hues that you
can build into the
app as well.
FRED CHUNG: Do you have an
example of a custom view or is
that still something that's
in the works?
DAN LEW: I think it's
still in the work.
But I did play around
a bit with--
there's this adapter interface
if you want to create your own
info window pop-ups or
info window content.
And I played around with
that for a bit.
But I haven't actually
used it yet.
FRED CHUNG: OK, cool.
And as I'm panning around
downtown for certain retail
stores, it's showing me the
indoor map for those
locations, which
is pretty cool.
DAN LEW: Yeah, it's really cool
to have all the features
that the current Google Maps
app has in our own map.
FRED CHUNG: Now that you've
taken a look at the API, what
are some of the features that
interest you, that you are
excited about?
DAN LEW: I think a lot of the
things I'm excited about are
just all the things that, with
the old map view, we had to
roll on our own.
So for example, we used
to have to make
our own pop-up bubbles.
We used to have to write our own
draw routines to lay over
all the lines or whatever
we wanted on the map.
And now, all of that stuff is
built into the library.
And it's just a lot
easier to use.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
And I notice that as you zoom
closer into the map, 3D
buildings start to pop up
left and right, which is
kind of cool also.
It gives the user some visual
cues of their orientation.
DAN LEW: Yeah, and I mean, with
hotels, I feel like the
map's a core part of
the experience.
It's incredibly important to see
where you are on a map and
what hotels are nearby.
Or if you're going to visit
someone else, you want to see
all the hotels that are nearby
where they're living.
So an improved map experience
really makes a big
difference to users.
FRED CHUNG: Definitely.
Shall we take a quick look at
your other application?
DAN LEW: Sure.
FRED CHUNG: FlightTrack I just
launched FlightTrack.
I have a saved route.
I clicked on it.
And I have the start time.
And this flight is
in progress.
And I clicked into
the map view.
It shows me a flight between
San Francisco and JFK.
DAN LEW: For this one, for the
Expedia hotels, we're mostly
just using markers
and info windows.
But here, we're really using
a whole array of features.
So for example, it looks like
today there's a whole lot of
weather around, kind of, the
south belt right now.
So we're using a ground
overlay for that.
And actually one of my favorite
things, we used to
have to download the bitmap
and then add alpha
transparency on our own.
And now, the ground overlay, I
can just make it transparent
right from the API itself.
And we're also using
poly lines to
represent the flight path.
And actually, one of the cool
things there is it supports
geodesic poly lines right out
of the box, which is one of
those things that before, we had
to calculate by hand all
the different ways of doing
the shortest distance on a
Mercator projection.
And now, we just get that
in the library as well.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
It sounds like you're getting a
number of features for free
in this update.
DAN LEW: Yeah, a whole
bunch of them.
FRED CHUNG: Right.
I'm just looking at the weather
information that you
have added on the overlay.
It looks pretty cool.
So Dan, one question is that
from an engineering
standpoint, what sort of effort
is involved when you
need to incorporate
the new API?
DAN LEW: Well, I think initially
you need to do a lot
of reading of the documentation
because the new
API is really nothing like
the old map view.
I mean, for one thing,
it's fragment-based.
It's modern.
The whole itemized overlay
paradigm is out the window.
It's completely different.
So it took a bit of time to
read through all that.
But ultimately, the new library
is just so much easier
to use that it really only took,
I think, two days to
convert our existing apps to
using the new library.
FRED CHUNG: That's great.
So I assume you are planning
to launch soon, these apps?
DAN LEW: Yeah, as soon as we get
a chance to really update
and polish it and make sure that
there's no issues just
lingering around that we haven't
tested properly yet.
FRED CHUNG: All right, cool.
I look forward to seeing the
updates on Google Play.
DAN LEW: Yeah.
Thanks.
FRED CHUNG: Thank
you very much.
DAN LEW: Have a nice day.
FRED CHUNG: All right, thanks.
Bye.
Good stuff.
I wanted to say thank you to
our friends from Trulia and
Expedia for sharing
their feedback.
So for the developer audience
out there, I bet you really
want to check out the new API.
You can get it now by
downloading the latest Google
Play Services from your
Android SDK manager.
Play around with the API.
And let us know what
you think.
We look forward to seeing the
kinds of innovation that you
can do with the API.
Thank you.
MANO MARKS: Great.
Thanks.